I'm going to carry on now with our
next presentation for this budget workshop.
And now we will shift to gears to hear from
the Mayor's office. And at this time, I would like to welcome
our Chief of staff for the Mayor's office, ms. Marvelette Hunter
and Valerie Barry, to provide the Mayor's Office department
budget presentation. I want to thank you all for your presentation station
and turn the floor to you. Excellent. Good morning,
chair and council members and council
representatives. I am here today with our CFO,
Valerie Berry, and Valerie has ridden side
chair with me for the last six budget presentations, so really
glad that she is here. We also have several members of
the Mayor's office executive team who are present,
and I would like for them to please stand and be recognized
right now.
Thank you all. I may have
a couple of them come forward during our Q and A time period.
If you have any additional questions that relate to their
specific areas of expertise. After I finish
the budget this year, I'm excited to be able to be here with
you in person instead of virtually, which was our last
fate. We have certainly had our fair share
of challenges through this administration, but just like
Houston, we've proven that we are resilient and that we can come through anything,
even a global pandemic. I'd like to publicly thank the city
of Houston for their support of Mayor Turner and this
administration. And I also want to thank the 22,000
employees who work tirelessly to serve
the citizens of Houston. Today.
I'm pleased to present to you the FY 23 Mayor's Office proposed
budget. And if we could have our first slide,
please.
Here is the Functional organization chart summarizing our
six General fund divisions. First,
we have our executive offices, which includes our boards
and commissions, education,
constituent services, community relations and our council
relations. Next we have our Agenda office,
the Economic Development Office, government relations,
Communications and our Veteran Affairs Office.
You'll note here the total budget for each of the
six divisions as well as the number of
FTEs for each of those respective divisions.
Next slide, please.
There are two special revenue funds administered
by the Mayor's office. First, we have our Cable
TV Special Fund, whose functional organization
chart you see before you with the budget and the number
of FTEs that are represented.
Next slide, please.
You'll see here the other special fund, which is
our Tourism and Promotion Special Fund.
And this organizational chart shows the budget and
the FTEs for each of those respective
divisions. The tourism and promotion fund
includes our special events, trade and international
affairs, and it also includes cultural affairs.
Next slide, please.
The next four slides are going to share
with you our course services within the Mayor's office.
First we looked at divisions that are mandated by federal
or state statutes or municipal code. And then
we looked at divisions that were created to meet the needs of the citizens
of Houston. Now, although most of our divisions are
not statutorily required,
the citizens of Houston certainly depend on those services that we
provide on a daily basis.
So on this particular slide, you see our Office of Education, our Boards
and commissions and our Constituent Services divisions.
And I just wanted to note just a couple of highlights from each one of
those and the rest is there for your reading but heart
Houston youth. That is one of the Mayor's signature initiatives
and that is administered through our Education Office.
And we are on track currently this year to provide 12,000
jobs for our youth ages 16 to 24.
And I will make note that when that program first started, we were only
providing 450 jobs. And now we have brought on the private
sector and all of the additional jobs now are private sector
related. I'll also
note that as far as our Boards and Commissions is concerned,
we have, and many people don't know this, over 160
Boards and Commissions, and that's a lot of people that
we have to administrate over. And then lastly, for Constituent
Services, just making a note that there are approximately
1400 pieces of correspondence that comes in to the Mayor's
office on a monthly basis. And with a very lean staff
of two, we're able to move that and be responsive to
the citizens of Houston. Next slide, please.
Here we have our agenda office, the Economic Development
office and the Special Events office. And all of these
are statutorily mandated. I wanted
to highlight a couple of things, and that is through our Economic Development Office.
This is our office that administers the tours, the management
districts, the tax abatements, and is responsible for
over $25 million in billings through
the Industrial Assessments each
year. And then I wanted to also make note of our
Special Events Office. Now that we are past COVID or post COVID
and beginning to return to our mini events,
this particular office produces about 2000
special events per year for the City of Houston.
Next slide, please.
Here we have our Intergovernmental Relations Office, our Cultural
Affairs, as well as our Veteran Affairs. And I wanted to
highlight that our Gr team was
mainly responsible for helping to bring $630,000,000
of ARPA funds, which is really being
relied upon to help us get through not only this year,
but the next two years of deficits
that we were experiencing due to COVID. So very important,
their work that they're doing. And then our Veteran Affairs.
I wanted to point out that Houston hosts the second largest
veteran population in the country,
over 300,000 veterans, and this office basically
provides services, referral services to that population.
Next slide, please.
Lastly, we have our communications office and our trade and
international affairs and also Houston Television.
And I wanted to point out that, of course,
communications statutorily required by the Texas
Public Information Act. But I wanted to point out that we receive
about 170 TPS per year and
over 270 requests for proclamations
or letters from the Mayor's office. And so that
is a very busy office with a
staff of two in trade and international affairs.
This office is critical in coordinating the Mayor's
abroad trade missions and also in marketing
the City of Houston as an international city which
we're very proud of. And then, lastly,
Houston television. And that
is mandated by Chapter 37 of the City of Houston Code of Ordinances.
And of course the impact is better transparency of
government and making sure that we have an informed public.
Next slide please.
This slide summarizes our revenues for the three funds
that are managed in the Mayor's office. We have our general fund
and we also have Houston television special revenue
fund and the tourism and promotion special
revenue fund. From our FY 22 estimate,
the General Fund has increased in revenues of
approximately $887,000 for
FY 23 and this is primarily due to the
projected revenue from the new Digital Kiosk,
which will begin generating revenue in the fourth quarter of
22. The revenue projected for FY 23
is for a full year of those revenues and
the revenue projection for FY 22 was only prorated
for a May start date. So there's also a
$33,000 increase in the
Industrial District assessment revenue due to the expected
increase in taxable values by 6.3 million.
For our Houston Television Fund, we are projecting
an overall revenue decrease of 69,000
over the FY 22 estimate and
this is primarily due to the projected decrease of the Peg fees,
the public education and governmental revenues. And this is something that
I've been sharing with Council for the last few years.
That trend is continuing. Finally, for our Tourism
and Promotion Fund, we are estimating an approximate $2.95
million increase in revenue from our FY
22 estimates and the increase is primarily
due to the projected post pandemic
increase in hotel Occupancy tax revenues,
which we're very excited about based on information that
has been provided by Houston. First, as you will recall, the FY
21 revenues took a substantial hit as
a result of COVID nineteen's impact and
so we are now projecting for FY 22
having a gradual comeback and for FY 23
revenue budget reflects a very strong return
to pre COVID activity. Next slide please.
This slide reiterates the largest drivers of the revenue
increases and decreases for FY 23 and most of which
I discussed on the previous slide. General Fund revenue
from the Digital Kiosk contract,
HTV, the Peg, contributions from state franchise fees
and a chargeback to funds for HTV.
And lastly, tourism promotion. The hot receipts
come back to pre COVID levels.
Next slide please.
This slide captures the expenditure comparison for all of
our funds between the year in FY 22 estimate
and the FY 23 proposed budget. So the
General Fund shows an expenditure increase of
$230,000 or 2.9%.
However, this percentage includes the net adjustments which I'll
talk about a little bit later for contractual municipal hope,
pay increases, health insurance and restricted
accounts. The almost $2.1 million
increase in Houston Television Special Revenue Fund is primarily
due to the projection in capital projects from
year to year. So the FY 23 planned
capital project improvements include the upgrade for
the City Hall chambers, video control room,
which was much needed, the new build of the City Council
chambers and the terminal room along with the
few much smaller projects. So these funds are
capital dollars that are restricted for capital use only,
so they cannot be used for administrative purposes.
In the Tourism Special Revenue Fund, we project an increase of
$3.1 million in expenditures or
17.47% from the FY 22
budget. And this is primarily due to the increase in the city's
net receipts of the hot taxes and thus the
city's payment going out to the arts
partner houston Arts Alliance is projected
to increase. As noted earlier, our FY
23 budget reflects a strong return to precovid
activity and therefore, again an increase in
the payment to the arts partner is anticipated.
Next slide please.
The next three slides provides a graphic representation
of our personnel versus non personnel budgeted
expenses for the Mayor's office's three funds.
So to elaborate on that, the Mayor's Office General fund
is 65% personnel expenditures.
Of the remaining 35%,
68% of that is for the general fund
transfer to subsidize special events.
So the restricted accounts comprise 22% of this portion,
leaving only 10% of the non
personnel budget for services and supplies and
those things like the novice account, office expenses,
travel, parking and the like.
Next slide, please.
The Houston Television Special Revenue Fund is 26%
personnel expenditures. Of the remaining 74%,
more than half is for the planned capital improvement
and more than a third is for the contractual payment to
Houston Media Source. And this is the city's
public access channel partner. The services and supplies
account for only 6% and the restricted accounts
also take another 6% of this portion.
Next slide, please.
Lastly, the tourism promotion special revenue fund
is 15% personnel expenditures and
85% other. And please keep in mind
that this is the fund where we receive our hot taxes. So therefore
the personnel budget is relatively very
small.
92% of the other charges are to pay the arts
partner for the hot agreement and then supplies and
services are there for only about 7% of the other
for the entire fund. Next slide
please.
This slide gives a great summary of the
net change in expenditure budget from FY 22
to FY 23. The slide illustrates the net
increase of $230,000 from
the FY 22 budget to FY 23 proposed
budget. And this represents a
2.9% change as
discussed on slide number eleven.
So beginning at the very top of
this chart, you'll see that the Mayor's office FY
22 operating budget is $6.95
million. So once we add to that our restricted
account budget of 621,000 FY
22 contractual municipal hope increases of 3% of
140,000 revised projection of
restricted accounts of 76,000 the
FY 22 council surplus of
10,000, which was granted to us from council member Cisanero's
Office for an Intern, and the Mayor's Office of Education and
Funding for marketing specialists and special events and
program adjustments that we took in the Economic Development
Office for a total FY 22 budget of
$7.9 million.
Now, the next two areas, shaded areas on the chart,
the blocks include our proposed operating budget adjustments
for FY 23, and the first item
is the reverse of the one time funding from Council Member Cisnero's
office, the FY 22 surplus,
FY 21 surplus, and the balance of the annualized
funding amount for the economic development programming.
So, added to this are the contractual adjustments
for hope increases, health and benefits offset
by a reduction in the restricted accounts taking.
All of the increases and the decreases from the FY 22
operating budget yields the proposed FY 23
budget of $8.16 million
for the Mayor's office. Next slide,
please.
This slide provides a brief narrative of each fund's expenditure highlights
for your reference, and we discuss the expenditure highlights that are
listed on slide number eleven. The general
fund expense budget includes funding for contractual municipal
hope pay increases, health benefits and
restricted accounts. And some of the highlights of the fund include
funding for capital improvements through Houston Television
and in the Tourism Promotion Special Revenue Fund,
the increase being attributed to the increase in hotel
occupancy tax.
Next slide, please.
This concludes the financial portion of the Mayor's Office FY
23 budget presentation. For your reference, we have
included our office demographics and
some just some of our FY 22 accomplishments
in the appendix section. Thank you, and I'll be
happy to answer any questions that you may have. And we also
have our executive staff here in chambers to assist with questions
that you may have regarding their specific areas of focus.
I know that we have Andy Icken here from economic development.
Why don't you all stand up everybody.
So thank you all so much again. So we
do have Ted Irving who is here, we have representatives
from Veteran Affairs and we have representatives from
Special Events as well as our Executive Offices. So turn
it over to you. Any questions that you may have, we're happy to answer.
Thank you very much, Ms. Hunter. And your staff is well represented.
Great to see everyone here in the chamber with you. We also
have been joined by a few colleagues and staff
members. Council member Sally Alcorn has joined us and has been here this
morning along with staff from council member Tasha Jackson
as well as council member Michael Kubosh's office. So I
wanted to acknowledge everyone here, we do have a couple of our council
members in the queue before we get to our public speakers,
but first, let's hear from Council Member Alcorn.
Thank you, Chair, and thank you ms. Hunter,
the big increases were in the HTV and then to
the arts. I think I submitted those in writing, but you've covered them here.
So I appreciate that. If we could have you or Mr. Irving elaborate a
little bit more on the capital improvements that are being made.
This include what's already been done in the chamber? Is more stuff coming?
What's going on in the control room? A little bit more color around
what I will allow serving to provide a
little bit more detail regarding some of the improvements.
But as you recall, we did a lot of improvements
here. The lighting, of course, the sound. We still have
some additional work to do. And those funds that we have that
are part of the budget are specifically for capital improvements only.
So you will see some additional work, but I'll allow him to elaborate further.
Good morning. Good morning.
To answer your question on the capital improvements, the city
council horseshoe area was a phase
one. And so the phase two is the control
room that is behind this space.
And at one point in time, that control room as
well as the annex chambers control room had not been updated.
There have been no updates excuse me, since 1997.
They are extremely outdated. But due to the Cares
Act, the annex control room has been
modernized with virtual technology. In the next phase,
the new build that Chief Hunter is discussing that we are working to have
started here, hopefully in July, FY 23,
will be this control room to have it modernized.
Thank you, Council Member and Mr. Irving, I know having worked with you recently
on the technology, the TTI committee, we are still tweaking
some things. So, council Member, it is very much an ongoing
program with coordination with the speakers and the It
platforms and HTV, of course, trying to coordinate
it all. So we thank you for that ongoing effort. Next we'll
hear from Council member Cayman staff.
Thank you, chair. Thank you, Ms. Hunter. Ms. Hunter, I was
curious if you could speak to, given the city's budgetary
constraints, any unmet needs or
really particularly critical unmet needs that you all have identified.
Well, I don't think we have any critical unmet needs
at current. I think the biggest challenge that we face is that over the
last several years, we have trimmed our budgets and kept everything
very, very tight. And so in some instances,
we've actually had to eliminate vacancies.
And therefore our staffing is at a minimal right
now. So as we continue to respond to citizens
calls and all of the other things that we have to do within
the office, it does present a challenge. But as far as unmet
met needs, I don't think that we have any major ones at this point.
Thank you for that question. We have a follow up question now in the queue
from Council Member Alcorn. Thank you, Chair. On the Kiosk revenue,
how many kiosks does that represent? Trying to
remember. I think we have a contract for 25, but I'm going to have Andy
Icken to come forward and answer those specific questions. Thank you.
Good morning, Mr. Ickin. Welcome to the chamber.
Good morning. Chief of staff is correct. The first segment,
if you remember, council passed the first 25. We're well on the way
to do that right now. They have been very well received and
the advertising revenue was exceeding the expectations that we had at that
time. I just saw one going in this morning as I was coming in
on Prairie and Fanon. So that'll be 25
within 75. 75 within
fiscal year 23. Yeah, we're doing about five a month right now.
That's the pace at which they are letting contracts and doing everything right
now. I wouldn't be surprised if they don't come back to us
very soon. If remember, we put a pause at 25.
All the feedback we're getting, I'm not sure if council has any direct feedback
has been very positive. Thank you.
It might be helpful, director and chief,
to see a map of all of that. I know at some point to get
that update would be very we have such a map and we'll get that for
you. Excellent. Very good. Well, I believe that is it for comments from
the Horseshoe. Both council and staff have had their opportunity to
speak. So we'll turn to those in public comment
with the five virtual speakers that have signed up.
We're seeing two of whom are here online or
perhaps three. And we're going to start with Ms.
Saba Blanding. Ms. Blanding, we may 1
hear from you. Good morning.
Thank you for your time. I had a couple of questions.
The first was that on slide two it says the executive office
develops and coordinates all city policies.
Can we return to a budget hearings where the public can ask department directors
their questions directly? If not, why not? And then
my second question is on slide 28. You mentioned
initiatives with Houston's unhoused community. What efforts are being
made to be proactive and mitigate evictions? Our housing
department is grossly underfunded with a budget of only $400,000.
Houston renters, I mean, to quote the Houston Chronicle, houston renters are
now more cost burdened and evicted at a higher rate than renters
in Dallas, Chicago or Atlanta.
In 2019, one in eleven renter households in Harris County had an
eviction notice posted on their door. I know Harris and Houston are different,
but we have a lot of overlap. And an analysis by the eviction lab
at Princeton University found 16 Houston apartment complexes have
filed for more than 100 evictions each and over the course of the pandemic.
So the first question is about thank you, Ms. Landing,
Ms. Blanding, thank you for your question. Your time has expired.
Give the chief the option to respond. But I think we, as you
understand, have been restricted by the instruction
of the administration and seeing no council
members in queue to respond, we will move on to our next
speaker, who is Ms. Lien Chong. Ms.
Chong, if you're with us, we'll give you a moment to hit
star six to unmute or otherwise speak up and we'll
hear you.
Hello, can you hear me? Yes, Ms. Chong. Go ahead.
We hear you and see you online. Yes, ma'am. Thank you.
Awesome. So I am an artist
and I'm an organizer for Arts Accountability Houston.
And we have many engaged artists who
are advocating for
public funding for the arts here in Houston.
Now, we are aware of a proposal that's been sent to the mayor by
the Cultural District for Arca funding to
be allocated to the arts in Houston.
I'd like to sort of as a member of the public Advocate
for these fundings to go to
fund the arts here in Houston. I know it's not on the budget,
but we are curious to know when
these funds will be confirmed from
the city to support the arts here in Houston.
Any organizations are still suffering as
a result of the pandemic and we
would really like for the city to allocate
ARPA funding towards the arts here in Houston.
Thank you very much, Mrs. Chong. We're well aware of the ongoing
challenges for our arts community and thank you very much
for bringing this question to council. It is something that
we are working on with local organizations and appreciate
you calling our attention to it and we will
stay vigilant with that item. Next, we'll hear from Mr.
Yes, ma'am. Thank you. We will respond accordingly.
Our next speaker is Mr. Jason Oliver.
Mr. Oliver, if you're with us
or hit star six to unmute, I'm here.
Good morning. First, I want to speak up in
support of Leanne and the arts
proposal. Like, there was significant losses and hot
taxes and using ARPA funds for revenue replacement would be
a great idea to kind of stimulate the economy and economic
activity in Houston. First, and so along
those lines, it's come up before, but I'm interested in the process for approving
ARPA fund suggestions. Can you share that process and any rubric
that exists? Also, I would like to see the proposals that
have been received by the mayor's office thus far. And then second,
HTV feels like an under celebrated entity within the city,
but it's vital for transparency. As Ms. Hunter mentioned,
the expenditures accepting a two and a half million furniture
and equipment line item seemed flat decreasing over the past six years,
even with the pandemic going on. I'm wondering if
HTV saw an increased workload during the pandemic and if there
was an increase in overtime or other pay, because I'm not seeing it
in the line items. Thank you. Thank you, Mr. Oliver.
I'm going to pick up on your final point there about the good work of
HTV. And I know council members have been
encouraged to utilize that facility and that
ability for us to really program according to some of
the highlights of what we're doing around City Hall. So,
again, thank you for your question, for being here with us virtually.
And Ms. Hunter, again, I want to thank you for your presentation today,
for your team being here with us in chambers.
And with that, we will take a break and resume
after lunch this afternoon at 01:00 with presentation
of the budget workshop. Our next group to hear from will be
our legal department. And with that, our break commences.
Thank you, Chair. Thank you, Council.
Share the investment priorities identified by the Eastwood Civic Association.
We need relief on three lines to improve mobility in our community.
I will speak to the Galveston sub and my neighbor Lindsay, who's up next,
will speak about east and west belts later on the Galveston sub.
Our top priority is an underpass on lockwood, which was in the presentation.
This is the expected route of Metro BRT's University
corridor line. But let me be clear. Our neighborhood believes an overpass
in this area wouldn't be the right solution. We are instead in favor
of a small underpass that would provide the community with one additional north south
crossing, but still leave seven crossings aggregate that
are blocked daily. As such, I urge the city of Houston to also
seek funding for a rail improvement study on this line to explore alternative
solutions that address the entirety of the sub, not just one crossing.
And this needs to be done in conjunction with Metro to ensure solutions can
be expedited to align with the timelines for BRT construction.
Thank you, Chair. My colleague Glimpsey will share priorities for East End,
West Belt or east and west belts in her remarks. Thank you.
Thank you very much, Ms. La Perrier, and we'll proceed
with the I believe hold on. Before you leave the podium, we have a question
from Chair Gallegos. Thank you,
Daniel, for being here today and representing Eastwood. Just for your
information, a couple of weeks ago, I did meet with the new board
chair, Sanjay, and did bring that to his attention.
He came into my office that there are concerns in regards to
the BRT going down lockwood, in regards to an
overpass that may be constructed or an underpass.
So they are aware of it and we are going
to be monitoring it. Thank you. Thank you, council member.
Proceed to our next speaker. Thanks again. Ms. Lindsay Williams
with us virtually and online. Proceed, ms Williams.
If you'd hit star six to unmute,
we'll await your comment.
Ms. Lindsay Williams,
online.
We see you online. If you can unmute
star six,
we can come back to you if there are technical challenges.
With that nice intro from Danielle, I'm sorry we can't take it
right to Ms. Williams, but we'll come back to you if we can.
Mr. Tom Thompson, also online, virtually testing
our system here. Mr. Thompson, are you there? Are you able to mute
unmute, please. Unmute.
We see you, Mr. Thompson, and we
know we heard you at the public session this week at council.
We're checking our system to see if there's any technical challenges
right now, but proceeding with our list, a call for either
Ms. Williams or Mr. Thompson online.
And while we're addressing the challenges there, we will proceed.
Present here in chambers is Punkaj Wadha.
Punkage is here with us. Let's hear from you at the podium,
sir. Thank you for being here. If you could state your name for the record
and proceed with your question or comment.
Yes, sir. Thank you.
Good morning. Good morning,
Council. Good morning. Thank you for holding this meeting. Thank you, BNSF,
for being present, providing vital
rail services to our city and the country. I just want to say I love
trains. I enjoy counting train cars with my kids
as they roll by when I'm stuck at one of the block crossings,
unfortunately. My name is Punkage Wadhwa. I'm part
of the Houston Quiet Zones Committee, and I'm one of the residents in the
neighborhoods that are near the BNSF rail line that runs
parallel to the 34th street tracks just north
outside of 610 Loop on the northwest side from the neighborhoods
from Oak Forest all the way to Independence Heights. As you can see on
the map I provided you guys, there are over 500
households that have voiced their support for the 34th
Street Street quadzone corridor. Considering each
household typically has two to four residents, there are at least several
thousand Houstonians impacted by the train horns on this
stretch of tracks. It's time to
silence the train horns in Houston's. People in countries around the
world live in communities that are much
more dense without the obnoxiously loud train horns.
Houston can do the same. We don't live in the 18 hundreds with coal
fired trains belching out black soot black soot
and polluting the environment, do we? Then why should we live with
an outdated safety measure as a train horn? The train horn
is the last resort for emergency situations, notifying anyone
to get off the tracks, same as it is for
when we drive our vehicles. We don't honk our horn every
time we drive through an intersection.
We don't honk our horn when we change lanes.
So we have safety measures in place. And we have the technology
to mandate, per the City of Houston infrastructure
Design manual, to put these measures in place and have horns only as
a last resort. Per the FRA.
The City of Houston has the authority to mandate this,
to put effective quiet zones in place, as you guys have discussed earlier
today, and I know you guys are in process of doing that, but we
need to do this now. It's long awaited. You guys are
part of the quality of life committee. It's now time to make this better
for all citizens. Quality of. Life, especially the thousands of Houstonians
that have just advocated for this. If I
may have one more minute. Well, you can conclude your remarks. Yeah,
I have one more minute. I'll give you a few more seconds. I'm speaking
on behalf of thousands of members of we have a long way to go today,
Mr. Padwa. Thank you. Okay. Regarding funding and costs of the quiet
zones, I don't think the city should be burdened with this, nor the taxpayers.
Let's look at BNSF's financial statement. In 2021,
they had 22 billions in revenue, 13 billions in expenses,
with a net income of 7 billion. Now, if you look at the
number, 350,000 was mentioned earlier as a cost
per. If you'd like to intersection,
we can take your comment online and we'll be happy to post it and
circulate it to the committees. But thank you again for being
here. I appreciate asking your question. I appreciate you allowing me to speak.
If you could wrap up, you're looking at 0.3% of BNF's profits
to implement a $2 million quiet zone along the
34th street corridor. Thank you
very much. Appreciate that.
Proceeding now to our next speaker. We're going to try again for online.
Our speaker is Ms. Orlando Pulito.
Ms. Pulito, if you're here,
please join. There you are. Okay, thank you.
Ms. Pulito, we can hear you. Hello?
Go ahead, ma'am. We can hear you. Okay,
thank you for allowing me a few minutes to speak. So I
submitted in writing my concerns to back up
what I'm speaking of today. So with the railroad I've been in this
community for a very long time, and I'm just
very upset. The fact that the railroad is sitting there
talking about they have daily conversations,
monthly meetings, but yet there's no solution. In addition
to this blocking of vehicles
having to reroute include massive 18 wheelers
trying to get to these back industries, these are
neighborhoods. These are small streets. And these massive trucks
navigating through the community are not only tearing up our streets,
but more importantly, we have a trail,
walking trail. We have a park, but our wires
sit low when they come through here, and I've already reported this numerous times,
they cause damage to my house in more ways than one. They have
popped my Internet wires, causing my whole house
to be damaged. They forced their way
in anyhow possible any way possible. And I've submitted pictures of
that. We have children riding their bikes.
We have people. We have older seniors walking.
These trucks are trying to get to this industry. They're trying to
exit this industry. Our community streets are not for that.
And the young man before me was talking about
the revenue. Yeah, there has to be alternative ways
in these meetings that they have to put this revenue in
effect. But more importantly is,
yeah, we need solutions and we need them quickly.
Thank you very much, Ms. Pulito. We do have the handout that you brought
or delivered to us with the photographs that you mentioned. So thank you
for that, and we
will post those and circulate. So thank you again for your comments
and being here. Seeing no questions from the council, we're going to proceed to the
next speaker, which is Ms. Mara Gomez.
Ms. Gomez is here with us in City Hall chambers,
so thank you for being here. If you join us at the podium, we'd love
to hear your comment or question today for the council.
If you could identify yourself. Yes, good morning.
My name is Mana Gomez, and I am with Link Houston, a nonprofit
that advocates for a robust and equitable transportation network so that
all people can reach opportunity. Today, I am addressing this joint committee
about the increasing burden train blockages continue to pose
for transit riders, bicyclists, and pedestrians in
the East End and Fifth Ward communities. Link Houston
shares many of the concerns residents are sharing with you today.
I live in the East End, so I experience firsthand the impact
these train blockages have on our communities.
We are forced to reroute to access jobs,
education, health care and wellness,
recreational opportunities, and other essential destinations.
For example, while riding Metro's 40 local bus
route, one day, the driver had to reroute along the I 45
frontage road and missed ten stops on both
sides of the train blockage. Several Metro bus routes are
often forced to redirect when trains block a crossing,
causing people to be late to their destinations. Some pedestrians,
school age children included, go under or over in between
the cars of trains of stopped trains blocking
their route and risk their lives by doing so. Pedestrians will
try to find the quickest way to their destination, especially if they're
being late affects their quality of life.
Additionally, they can force bicyclists to reroute
onto busier streets, which may not have the built in
infrastructure to afford sufficient safety.
So today, we ask the Federal Railroad Administration,
Up, BNSF and the KCS rail
companies to work with our local elected officials and communities to
find the best community driven solutions to these train blockages
with our most vulnerable road users in mind, and without further dividing
the communities the railway infrastructure goes through.
And we ask our elected officials to help hold these companies accountable
and do right by the communities they operate in.
Your efforts to remedy these issues will remove adverse
barriers and bring about equity in historically underserved
areas. Thank you. Thank you very much, Ms.
Gomez, for your comments. Seeing no questions in the queue,
we'll proceed. I see that Ms.
Williams has rejoined us or hopefully is able to
unmute Ms. Williams. Can you do that? There you
are. Yes. Can you hear me? Yes, go ahead. Loud and clear.
Perfect. My name is Lindsay Williams. I'm the Eastwood Civic
Association train committee chair, continuing to share our investment priorities.
Danielle started with on the west belt. We agreed
with the prioritization of York Street, presented by staff and included
in the ten year old rail district study. However, there is a critical missing
piece in Phase one needed to address the Nhhips plan.
In anticipation of the closure at Polk and St. Emmanuel, we would urge the
inclusion of an underpass at Leland as an equal priority. To allow Eastern
residents a straight access to downtown on the East Belt,
the community desperately needs at least one east west crossing,
either at Polk lawndale or telephone. Each crossing has its merits.
Polk serves as a route for Metro buses, lawndale would provide better
access to Kip School and post office, and the telephone may undergo
a complete transformation if the raised grant and Terra's 23 partnerships
come through. There are test choices, but we'd be happy to work with
the city to engage with the community on which crossing they would like to see
prioritize. Moving on from infrastructure to Quiet Zones
since at least 2011, the neighborhood has been seeking quiet zones
across the West Belt, East Belt and the Galveston Line. Each time, there's something preventing
quiet zones from moving forward, funding other priorities, or waiting
on no horn signs. Council, there are new Bil grants
which could solve for funding. We could
have had quiet zones implemented a long time ago with the use of grants to
improve infrastructure, but it feels like our voices have gone unheard. Money is
available now, and there seems to be no urgency at the city to apply for
dollars to improve quality of life in the East End. Projects have historically
been focused on the West Side, and it's time to see dollars helping those who
live east of I 45 put the money where the problem is,
and it's in the East End. Chicago is already celebrating Bil
dollars that they expect to receive, and we are already behind.
So, passing it back to council, how soon do you expect to have the first
proposals ready for funding from the Bil? And I hope you have an answer.
Well, Ms. Williams, I want to thank you for being here and asking your
question. I don't see any council members jumping at the
opportunity to respond,
but at the same time, well, there we go. We've got Council Member Chair
Alcorn here to address you. Ms. Williams. Thank you. Good question.
And we'll find out. And I just want to say I'm
so impressed with the Eastwood residents. I mean, you guys not only know
your comments are with such specificity that is so helpful
about what you exactly want. You have a lot of knowledge about the funding opportunities.
You guys know your stuff. And I for 01:00 a.m. Impressed by that and
will certainly do what I can to advocate for
what you're talking about. We are working very hard here.
Thank you, Ms. Williams. We have council member Gallegos also in the queue.
Thank you, Ms. Williams, for taking time to be here.
Just for your information, we have submitted a request to
congresswoman Garcia and congresswoman Sheila Jackson Lee
for funding for community project for the
east end quiet two zone. So we're
hoping that that will be approved. Thank you. Thank you
council member, and thank you Ms. Williams, for being here again
for your leadership in the community and bringing your question today.
So with that, we're moving on to the next speaker. We're going to try again
for Mr. Tom Thompson if he's back online
and able to join us, star six to unmute.
Otherwise, we're going to proceed with the
next speaker, which is Ms. Amy Din. Amy din
virtually with us, I believe.
Amy, are you there?
We're seeing you online but hearing nothing. Can you join
us with star six?
If not, we will proceed and hopefully get back from
you. The next speaker on the list is Mr. Clay Dippel.
Clay, glad you're with us. If you could approach to the podium,
happy to hear your question or comment today. If you could identify yourself for the
record. Thank you very much. I'm Clay Dippel,
I'm also a resident of Eastwood. I want to thank you committee members,
elected officials, chief pena, thank you. And to the railroads.
I also regret that the FRA could not make it. We have
established in several public meetings that the train blockages
in the east end have been increasing in frequency and in duration,
all while the trains themselves get longer, while Houston's
population grows. Union pacific tells us they expect train
traffic through our neighborhood is only going to increase with
just a $30 security camera at just one crossing
in Eastwood, private citizens have unmassed an incredible amount
of data to prove the scope of the blockage problem.
It's measurable, it's persistent, and it's about public
safety. The problem is only going to get worse.
We come now to urge the council to work with city public works starting
today to use this data and the data from these pilot surveillance
programs to create a concrete action plan.
We want to know how Houston can apply and allocate for
infrastructure dollars for grade separated underpasses completion
of long promised quiet zones and additional improvement studies so that a
comprehensive plan can give your constituents a clear understanding
of which projects you intend to apply for in each
year of the BIL's five available years.
Rail operators have long treated our neighborhood,
Eastwood like a parking lot for trains that are too long
by their own standards to fit in the switching yards built to accommodate them.
They don't even know which intersections they're blocking.
The people who live and work and shop and invest here want to see
boots on the ground to secure funding for a fix.
Please take ownership of this issue. Council members,
you are our voice. We need you to speak up for us. And I end
with a question for council. What are the city of Houston's funding
request priorities for alleviating rail blockage issues? And how
do you intend to involve the community in deciding which of these
improvements come 1st? First of all, Mr. Dibble, thank you very
much for being here today. And for your question for
response is Chair Gallegos.
Thank you, Chair. And thank you, Clay, for your continued advocacy.
I know you and others were at the town hall
held by the Easton Chamber as well as the Fifth Ward and
there at Guadalupe Church with Congresswoman Sheila Jackson Lee.
And thank you for the nice handwritten note. Appreciate that as
well. Thank you. Also, I just want to say
that's why it's so important that Union Pacific and Burlington
Northern are aware of this
triangle wish affects Eastwood Fire Station
18. Again, it doesn't happen often, but it does happen
where there's a train on all three tracks. So you're talking about
residents, you're talking about emergency vehicles.
Again, you're talking about parents that can't take their kids to school or
pick them up after school. So it's just chaos.
And that's why I'm asking Burnington Northern and Union Pacific to look
at this triangle and ask your dispatchers
to not stop trains within this triangle because
it impacts quite a few residents. Thank you. Thank you,
ma'am. Thank you, Chair. Great question. Appreciate you being here.
Our next speaker is Ms. Erica Miranda,
who I believe is online. This is Amy Den.
Okay. Can you hear me? Yeah. Let's hold off on the question for Ms.
Miranda and go back on our list for Ms. Din. We can hear
you, Amy. Go ahead. Thank you. Sorry,
somehow we had a misconnection, so my name
is Amy Denn. I'm the president of Super Neighborhood 64 and 88.
We appreciate your having the second meeting on railroad operations
after the January 2022 meeting.
Since your first joint Committee meeting in January, our Super Neighborhood conducted
a community survey regarding railroad impacts. And Mr.
Hannigritt presented at our February 9, 2022 Super
Neighborhood meeting to share the information with our community members specific
to our neighborhood. We also shared these results of that community survey
with Mr. Hannigriff, and we're happy to share that information with
any of the council members that are interested. We are glad
that Council is continuing to engage on this issue, the current railroad operations,
our safety issues for pedestrians, bicyclists, and vehicles
in our Super Neighborhood and their quality of life issues because of the
horns, noise, and impact of productivity for those traveling to work or school.
Our survey revealed the following concerns.
First extended and repeated block crossings for many hours
at Lawndale and telephone by the Kip post office at
Leland and Scott at Lockwood at
Rusk and Harrisburg on Hughes Street at Polk and Harrisburg
on Griggs at Redwood and Bobby Lee at the
Gus Worthham Golf Course, blocking the pedestrian bike and
Bayou Trail to Capitol Street for hours on Saturday morning.
The Dumble and Harrisburg Intersections.
And at 1500 Telephone Road near Sierrajo We
also experienced regularly horn noise
during the day and night and specifically illegal dumping
along the rail line at 300 north 67th
street in Houston, Texas. 77011 was
reported. We thank you for listening to our concerns and giving
us this form. The results of our survey are available by request.
You can send the request to me and I'm listed under Super
Neighborhood Council information. Thank you. Thank you,
Ms. Stan. Appreciate your comments and your ongoing work
on the issue as well. All right, we're now going to try for
excuse me. Hold on, Amy. Council Member Gallegos would
like to address you. Thank you, Amy. I just want to say thank
you for being here again. I know you addressed us in the January
meeting that we had. And thank you for representing
the Eastwood Lawndale Wayside super neighborhood again.
Twice in January and today. So thank you.
Thank you, Ms. Din. Our next speaker is Ms. Erica Miranda,
who is with us virtually. If you're online, speak up
or hit star six to Unmute.
Ms. Erica Miranda.
Okay, we'll put a hold on, Erica. If you join us,
please let us know or I'm here.
There you are. Okay, very good. Go ahead, Ms. Miranda.
Erica miranda. I'm an Eastwood resident.
I just wanted to say maybe the city
and the railroad can work on the low hanging
fruit, meaning the easy things. I would think
that it doesn't involve logistics because I work in
logistics and I know how hard that can be. But I'm thinking putting
up quiet stone signs does not inflict on
logistics. So that's something that can be worked on.
Also putting signs for alternate routes because there
are bus drivers that are new and they don't know the
routes around the neighborhood, it would be good for them along with
bus drivers both school and public.
Also, one of the roads that is used for
an alternate route coming off is Broadmore.
I know my mother lives between Broadmore and Munger and
the speed sometimes people are going 40, 50 and
maybe putting speed bumps or signs saying what the speed
limit is would be good. Also, one of
the roads that is used to do the back way to get access
to the access road and then get into the neighborhood again is
Knock Block Street. So that street is very
there's a lot of potholes. It's very narrow and it does need to be
fixed, I think for the time being until data is
put together and a long term or midterm solution
is done, maybe something like this can be a short term solution.
And also on the long term to think whether
it's an overpass or an underpass, think of the
people that walk. I know my mom walks to
the grocery store, so sometimes she's stuck waiting for
the train to start moving and sometimes she's waiting two or 3 hours
because of the whole COVID thing. She was not taking public transportation,
but instead she was walking and so her trip to
the grocery store, even though it's a 45 minutes walk for her,
it would end up being a four
hour transit time because she needed to wait for the train.
Thank you, Miranda. Move on. Thank you. Ms. Miranda. Council member
Gallegos would like to respond. Thank you,
chair. Ms. Minonda, you had mentioned that you
were hoping that we could have some kind of signs or something to let people
know that there's a train, therefore they don't spend their time going to that
crossing. I know that the public works has reached out
to my office and they are working on
some digital boards. I believe there's one going up at Lawndale near Griggs.
I believe there's one on Wayside, and I'm not sure where the other
1 may go, but hopefully in the near future,
that will be tied into the Smart railroad crossing.
So that way it lets the drivers know that there's a
train, for example, at the 5200 block of Lawndale, and therefore the
driver doesn't have to spend their time going over there to find out there's a
train blocking the crossing. Thank you.
Thanks again, Ms. Miranda, for being with us. And thank you for your question.
Next, we'll hear from Mr. Brandon Martindale,
who's with us virtually.
Or are you here in person? Mr. Martindale,
we've got you as being with us present, but I do not see you
take a second to look for you again. No.
And we'll go on to the next speaker, Mr. Kyle Rogers,
online. Mr. Rogers, can you
speak up or hit star six to join us?
Hearing none, looking online.
We'll call you again, Mr. Kyle Rogers virtually
with us, otherwise proceeding next to Sarah Gutierrez.
Ms. Gutierrez with us online,
presumably, if you can hit star six
or speak up.
It's been a long meeting. Folks may be getting some lunch. Ms.
Gutierrez, last call for you.
Otherwise, we'll move on to
Ms. Virginia Ivanias. Ms.
Ivanyez, if you are with us virtually,
we'll take a moment to hear from you or hit star six if you can
unmute and we're not seeing you online.
Can you hear me? This is Kyle Rogers. I'm sorry,
go ahead. Kyle Rogers with us. Thank you, Kyle, for joining. We can hear you.
Why don't you go ahead? Okay,
thank you. Hello. At a recent three
day NTSB national Transportation Safety
Board hearing on rail inefficiency, a former BNSF
supervisor stated that BNSF utilizes public
crossings as parking lots because its acceptable train lengths
exceed rail yard capacity.
Should public streets be used as de facto yards? I would
say no. But I want to know what does BNSF think?
What does up think? What does the FRA
think? What is an internally
acceptable stoppage time for a train to be blocking an upgrade
track crossing? Is it 30 minutes, 60 minutes?
120?
What are the reasons for the frequent blockages near BNSF
south yard, nearby telephone Lawndale and Polk
to up? What are the reasons for the frequent blockages
at the Galveston sub between Milby and Altic? Is it train length?
What investments or operational changes is BNSF
and up are making to reduce those blockages? We need
to know this. As of the last available data, trains are stopping
for over an hour on average, at the Galveston subline.
We want to work together with the city, federal regulators and railroads.
We have data. We can give you this data. But if you would
like something in return but we would like something in return.
We want minimal blockages. Children are
frequently tardied to school, affecting education. Goods are held up
at these blockages, affecting commerce. First responders are
rerouted during emergencies, affecting safety and health.
We urge our rail companies to keep
better blockage data and make it easier for the public to access. We urge
them to drastically improve their operations, especially in the East End.
We urge the federal representatives and regulators to look at how railroads
are operating and change the rules and laws to limit unnecessary,
unpredictable, and unprecedented blockages on our streets.
And lastly, we urge our city, county, and state officials
to help catalyze cooperation between us all. To this end,
we encourage any and all funding that will alleviate our
pain and be sought out and applications to be made. Thank you.
Thank you, Mr. Rogers. Great question, and I appreciate your willingness
to offer that data. We do have the representative,
Ms. Davis from BNSF, responding to your question. Ms.
Davis.
Sir, thank you very much for sharing.
Go ahead. Thank you, Mr. Chairman. Thank you very
much for sharing your concerns with us. We most certainly
are trying to move our trains as quickly and safely as we possibly
can through communities when there is an issue. As mentioned before, we try our best.
Our crews work to address those issues
and resume the movement of our trains.
So we'll certainly take your concerns back and talk to our operations
team and also work with Union Pacific to work
on that coordination and that handoff of our trains going in and out of our
yard as well. As I mentioned in my presentation before,
communication can always be improved. And so we are committed to both
communicating between our crews and our yard, as well as
between up dispatching and our crews.
Thank you, Ms. Davis. I want to thank you, Mr.
Rogers, again, for being here with your question. And I think with
that, we'll move on to the next speaker. And I'm told that Mr. Tom Thompson
is with us online. I'm going to try that now. Mr. Thompson,
can you unmute or identify hello.
There he is. All right, sir, go ahead with your question.
I'm sorry about the poor reception I have here.
No worries. Go ahead with your question or comment.
Sure. I just wanted to comment in
the presentation from Director Davis and Ms.
Summerlin, they pointed out some exciting new funding opportunities that
maybe could be applied for some of the issues we're talking
about here. Of course, it seems that all of them require
some kind of local match. And that's where it gets tough for us
because we have limited resources, as we all know.
But several years ago, the voters of Texas approved a
constitutional amendment that established
a Texas Rail Relocation and Improvement Fund.
This was back in 2005. Unfortunately, that fund
has never been funded by the legislature. It seems to
me that that could be a source of funding for the kind of projects we're
talking about here that could be used for our
match to get the federal funding.
And I'm a member of Texas Rail Advocates.
This organization is beginning a campaign now to solicit
letters of support that can be submitted to the
Texas State legislature prior to the 2023
session requesting them to actually allocate funding to the Texas
Rail Relocation and Improvement Fund. And I will be following up with
emails to the council members with more information.
Thank you. Thank you very much, Mr. Thompson, for making it to us
and for adding your comment for the public record. Thanks very much.
Thank you. Proceeding with our next speaker, I'm going to call again briefly,
virginia Yvonnez, who I don't believe is with us.
And following that call is one now for
Batiri Bankston, who I believe is with us virtually.
Batiri Bankston,
we're looking for phone number and seeing none.
If you're there, hit star six
or identify otherwise. Moving on then to our
next speaker is Mr. James Ganarelli. Mr.
Gonorelli virtually with us. If you
can speak up or hit star six to unmute
join us with your who do we have?
This is James gunrelli. Okay. Go ahead, Mr.
Gunrelli. Go ahead. Thank you, chair. Thanks for allowing me
to speak today. I've lived here for 16
years in the same house in the Fifth Ward, and I've experienced all
the issues that everyone else has mentioned from loud
horns, lots of blockages, being stuck in a triangle
where if you've got one behind you and one in front of you, you can't
go anywhere. Hour, 30 minutes, delays getting
to work, trying to do things in the evening. I'll submit the
more details on these intersections and also where 18 wheelers
are rerouting due to blockages that will shake
my bed at 530 in the morning. And I'll
send those for comment. Kind of ad living a little bit here because I
learned a lot today listening to everybody and I noticed two
themes that I would hope could be addressed.
One of them is that the onus continues to be on the citizens
to report the blockages through a website, a phone number,
so many different ways or three
step process on UP's website. I really then
with Mr. Bounds in the pilot program noticed
that more passive gathering of the data continuously real
time is going to provide much more benefit.
So the second part of it is there seems
to be so much request for funding that
will have to be out there that either comes from federal tax dollars, property tax
dollars, local match, everything else. And I noticed
with all those partners that were listed,
we unfortunately didn't see Union Pacific as one
of them on there. So I would hope that they could be
a willing partner, especially with as cheap as he said so that we can hopefully
turn this from not just a pilot program, but more into a
much more continuous one and to touch on what everyone else has said.
I remember in 2007 when Mayor Bill White took
a helicopter around and spoke about the arrogance of
the stops trains that were around here.
And since 2007, Union Pacific has spent
$48.2 billion on stock
buyback. Thank you very much Mr. Generally appreciate your comment. Your time has
expired. Appreciate that point. And with
up here still in the chamber today, I think
your point is a strong one for how they might continue to
step up or further step up. So I appreciate that comment from
you for the record today. Thanks again for being here.
And our next speaker on our list will move now to Mr.
Oscar Aguilar, who I believe is with us in
the chamber. Yes, sir. If you would come forward to the podium and
state your name for the record, we'd appreciate hearing from you,
Mr. Aguilar.
Thank you, Mr. Chairman. Yes, sir. Committee members,
I'm Oscar Aguilar, General Counsel for State Senator Carol Alvarado,
and today I'm here on her behalf and I will be reading a statement from
her. Dear committee members, as a native of the East End,
I have witnessed firsthand the logical and quality of life issues that
have resulted from the Blocket crossings in the East End.
Rail traffic has long kept our communities isolated from each other,
and as important as rail traffic is, the ability of our community to remain
connected is much more paramount. My district office is located
at the intersection of Lockwood and Harrisburg alongside a BC
rail line in the East End. On a weekly basis, trains luggagely move
through the neighborhood, often stopping and blocking multiple crossings
along the track. Consequently, many of my constituents daily routines
are often thrown off by the extensive weights and unnecessary detours
that these blockages cause. Moreover, first responders often
drive our office responding to calls for service, only to find block
crossings putting further distance between them and where they're needed.
The train disruptions largely affect the communities I represent,
and I am glad to see the city of Houston is working towards a solution.
I appreciate the initiative that the Houston City Council is taking to find solution
to this ongoing problem. The Smart Railroad Crossing Monitors pilot
program includes several BC crossings in my district, and I'm eager to review the
data that the program will produce. The federal funding solutions discussed
today are also a. Good step in the right direction. And I look forward to
your input on how state resources can be used to address the issue.
We must continue the discourse so that rail companies know that
this is an issue that can no longer be ignored and an issue that
will take significant action from their part to address. I look forward to our continued
work together to address the transportation and quality of life needs
of Houston and Senate District Six. Sincerely,
Carol Alvarado, state Senator for District Six. Thank you.
Thank you very much, Mr. Aguilar, and for the letter that
is here submitted for the record. Thank you to her and for
her involvement as a member of the Senate Transportation Committee.
I know we're very grateful for her service and for yours as well.
Council Member Gallegos. Thank you, Chair. Thank you,
Mr. Aguilar. And also thank Senator
Alvarado for the letter and for her support in our
efforts to address this issue. Thank you.
Thank you. Council member. Thank you, Chairman. Yes, sir. And thanks for getting that
onto the record. Returning now for a moment to our speaker. We understand Batiri
Bankson is with us online. Ms.
Bankson,
Batiri Bankston told
that you're with us online. If not, we will proceed.
Hit star Six or let us know you're there.
Otherwise we'll move on in the chamber. I believe with us
is Mr. Tony Garcia. Mr.
Garcia is here with us. If you'll come forward and identify
yourself, we'd love to hear your comment or question for the committees
assembled today. Thank you, Mr. Garcia.
Thank you, Chair Robinson. Thank you, Chair Gagos. So for those
of you that don't know me, I'm Tony Garcia. I'm a local East End resident.
I'm a businessman, community leader, philanthropist, and all around just
community servant. As I was here in this meeting
today, I was just blown away by the things that I've been hearing.
And I just want to give you my point of view. From my perspective,
the number ten comes to mind, and that is my everyday
task. It's ten. It's ten railroad crossings that are
blocked while I'm trying to access my child, to get
them to school, to see my mother, who is a grandmother and an
elderly woman, reporting to my office,
reporting to several of my businesses and reporting to my cafe.
Ten crossings every day that are blocked in
the East End. Resident that's Lawndale.
Leland Lockwood. Milby Oakhurst.
Polk. Scott samson,
Ernestine. And if I missed a few, my apologies.
This just has to stop. I do business elsewhere in
Houston and throughout Texas. And I can share with you that I don't encounter
ten blockings anywhere in Houston other than the East End. So at
what point did our lives become less valuable? At what point
did the city say it's okay for up and BNSF
to just park your trains on our tracks? This must stop now.
I heard earlier about detections and cameras and
quiet zones and how they know how they can detect when they're
approaching a quiet zone. Well, clearly an engineer is
certain he's blocking a track. They know what they're doing. And I can't
imagine that it's anything from mechanical failure when it happens
on a routine basis. Every single day they deliberately
block our tracks. It's hindering
our quality of life. It's a safety hazard.
It's as if every single day we parked a train outside
your home, BNSF and up, and said, you can't get out, you can't go
to the hospital, you can't take your child to school. We're just
going to park a track outside your house.
That's all I have. My name is Tony Garcia, and I thank
you for the time. Well, thank you, Mr. Garcia, for paying attention and for being
with us. Council Member Gallegos would like to address you. Thank you,
Chair. And thank you, Tony, for your time, for being here. I know you're a
busy man, and I know you are very active in the East End, so thank
you for everything you do for our communities in the East
End. And like you stated, Leland,
I know you have one of your offices there on Leland, just a block or
so away from the railroad track. So I can only imagine the frustration
that you and your employees go through not able
to get across that railroad track.
So, again, thank you for everything that you do. Thank you. Mr.
Garcia, if you would entertain one comment from Chair.
I know Council Member Gallegos and I were recently at
the botanical Garden, or right adjacent to it for a track completion
for part of our pedestrian and rail. And I rode my bike back
from there and was through your neighborhood and witnessed myself a
number of blocked intersections. And I know from
my route that I've got an app on my phone where I know exactly where
I went on that bike ride that day. And with your ten crossings,
I wonder if you know such an app that you could map your daily route.
Because what you just described to me is not only compromise
of your personal quality of life, but one that also is representing
what we're here fundamentally for today, which is public safety and the concerns that,
among others, chief Pena described. So I would love to see what
you described mapped. And if you need any help, let me know and I'll loan
you mine. I appreciate that, and I will be certain to map
it out for you and convey it to your office. Okay? Thank you for your
time. Thank you, Mr. Ricarcia. Thank you, Council. Okay, our next
speaker is with us online and virtually.
I believe that's Mr. Andrew Wright, if you're with us, hit star
six or speak up
and we can hear you now. Mr. Andrew Wright,
are you still with us?
Okay, we're hearing from Ms. Virginia Ivanyez,
who we think is online. If you're able to speak. We'd love
to hear from you. Ms. Ivanyez hit
star six to unmute.
Not hearing you. We're going to move on. I do see Mr.
Mark Klein with us in chambers. So let's move to your
comment. Mr. Klein, I believe you're on
the north side. I am, thank you.
If you could. Chair Althorn and Chair Geigos and Chair
Robinson. I appreciate it. I'm Mark Klein, president of Super Neighborhood Twelve,
and I've been working on the 34th street quiet zone since 2010.
And we've worked really long and hard. Thousands of
residents support it. It was a crushing blow when, in 2011,
the funding mechanism, which was rebuilt, Houston passed, and so the funding mechanism
for quiet zones went away. And so we spent the next seven years,
or at least I did, talking with Public Works jeffrey Weatherford, harry Hayes,
ellen Cohen, formerly City Council, District C,
and others. And we're told that there just wasn't any money
and that we'd have to find skin in the game to get the city
council to pony up its share. And I understand that. But the amount of money
we were talking about at the time, half million dollars,
that would be a momentous undertaking for any nonprofit to take,
let alone a bunch of volunteers. And so we were 9th on the
list when that list, eight of us, got completed. So when that list went away,
this is a list that had been vetted by council, by staff,
and then all of a sudden, we are facing that this has been reshuffled.
And now 34th street quiet zone could be anywhere on the list. And I just
want to make sure that it remains top of mind for you folks
and City Council, we're talking about the largest quiet zone that would
occur in Houston. It would impact thousands of residents.
It would improve the safety for their elementary schools, high three
high schools, the YMCAs on it. There are
affordable housing, apartment complexes on it. And most importantly,
there's an underserved community that has probably been underserved since it was formed in
1915. And that's Independence Heights. And this could be a huge
improvement for them. And they just built that new high school, burke or two.
Washington. It's an amazing thing, and I want to say that
I'm always confounded by Burlington Northern that
doesn't necessarily pay or contribute for some of these improvements.
No one's asking anybody to pay the full amount of this,
but they did make $7 billion in profits last year. And though some
of those profits are born on the backs of residents living along
these lines that suffer from the consequences of noise pollution,
which research has shown to be as egregious as air pollution,
but none of those costs are baked into those profits. And so this
is an opportunity for a brand to really get out ahead of itself and to
not only help its shareholders, but to help stakeholders in the community
improve their lives, improve their quality of life. I've seen firsthand what
noise pollution and the train horn can do. And so this is a great opportunity
for BNSF to improve life for thousands of Houstonians and
for city council as well. Thank you, Mr. Klein. Thank you very much for being
with us and your appeal to the industry. We appreciate that very
much. A few more speakers on our list. We will proceed
with virtually with Ms. Ruby Thomas.
Ms. Thomas, if you're with us at star six or
start talking, ms. Thomas,
Ruby Thomas looking for you online, star six.
Otherwise we will move on. Our next speaker is Ms.
Paulette Kukuk in the chamber
today. Ms. Kukuk, glad you're with us.
If you could take the podium and state
your name for the record. Congratulations for saying my
name correctly. Well, it's very difficult.
Hello, I'm Paulette Kakuk. I am a director with the
Eastwood Civic Association, and I would like to share some
information in regard to the intersections blocked on the Galveston
sub as a result of stop trains.
This data was collected by a surveillance camera directed
at the crossing at Eastwood dot number 85
95 22 y. In March of
2021, 218 trains traveled
this crossing, of which 26 stopped and blocked
the intersection for a total of 20 hours.
In March of 2022, we saw 188
trains travel this crossing, of which 63
stopped and blocked the intersection for a total of 73 hours
of blockages. That's 30 less trains,
but 37 more blockages and 52
more hours in a year to year comparison.
This illustrates that this problem is getting much worse.
Despite fewer trains traveling the track for the
last six months. I've painstakingly recorded the
details of every train that's traveled this crossing. Here's what
we learned. We see an average of 163 trains
a month. Of those,
34% of them come to a complete stop and block
the road for at least ten minutes.
The average duration of the blockage is 62
minutes. Each month,
this crossing is blocked for a total of 56 hours.
On average, the longest single blockage was
8 hours and 38 minutes. We see at least
one blockage of over 3 hours every month.
This is just a snapshot of what it looks like in the East
End. This is a single crossing on a single rail line.
The impacts are similar at other crossings on other
lines. We need the city to accelerate and
expand its smart railroad crossing. Monitor pilot.
I would like to ask council and staff, are there
plans to regularly share the data from the pilot publicly?
Thank you very much for your time. Well, thank you very much, Ms.
Kokokin. I think the intention is very much to share that
data. How we do that? I think we're taking
a good look at it with the partners who've presented today.
And I do see Mr. Hannigraff behind you, who presented
earlier, who may like to approach.
Can you please come forward, mr. Hannigraff, if you'd like to be
on the record with your comment or response? No, I've been
working really closely with the East End community and they have been providing us
the data to help us compile the entire story along
with our sensors. Excellent. And we know the concentration of
railroad crossings in the East End, the triangle that Council
Member Gallegos has been speaking of today. So we're grateful
for your data collection, your observations, and for working with our
team. Thank you very much. Thank you.
We do. Miss Kakuk, if you'd hold on, council Member Gallegos would like to
speak. Go ahead, sir. Thank you. Thank you, chair paulette,
if there was an East End award, you'd be the recipient of
the East End award for 2022. Can you please share
how you gathered all this information? Yes, I'd be glad to.
I bought a Wise camera for $30.
I mounted it at the back of the house because the train track is right
behind our house. And each day I look at
the data that's collected from the camera and
it records for 24 hours. I painstakingly look
at each time there is a stop train and how long
it stopped. I record it and I give it to
Danielle, who converts it into a chart.
Wow. So thank you.
Thank you for taking your personal time to do this for our community.
Thank you. Glad to. Thank you. Thanks. Ms. Cook and I
had a Lionel train when I was a kid. I want your help building that
next train set. You all
are awesome. We may be down to our final speaker on the list
before we call anyone who we've missed. Ms.
Melissa Bealer, I believe you're with us virtually.
Ms. Bealer, if you could hit star six or unmute going
once, going twice, and ask again for Ms.
Bealer to unmute or speak now
and hearing nothing there, I'm going to call any of those who may have missed.
And thank you,
Chief. My chief of staff has done an
incredible job. I want to thank Diana Caisedo,
as well as Daniel from Council Member Gallegas's office,
as well as Jordan from Council Member Alcorn's office, and the rest of
our staff. You all are doing great work for us. Thank you so much.
And we have been passed to two speakers who are with us in Chambers late
editions. But we do want to hear from everyone. Mr. John Segovia.
Mr. Segovia, if you're with us,
please state your name for the record.
And thank you for being here. Good morning,
Council. If it's still morning. It's not, but good
afternoon. My name is John Paul Segovia.
I open up an hello? If you could hold on speaker,
we'll take one more call in a moment, but Mr. Segovia, go ahead.
Thank you. My name is John Paul Segovia. I opened up an art gallery
in the East End about three years ago and it
sits in between five train tracks on Samson and Rusk.
So being there every day
for the last three years, I get to witness this firsthand
every day. So it's hard for my clients to get to appointments because
of daily train blockage. The biggest thing here
is the train horn abuse. Train conductors
will blare their horn for minutes at a time and it's very
annoying if you're trying to host an event there. You get
trains on both sides coming in and it's just a constant blare.
If there's trains parked on the track, then future trains
will come through there and still continue to blare their horn. So it's like,
who are they warning at that point if there's already trains blocking that
area? So when can we
expect the quiet zones to take place? Right?
I hear everybody talking about this,
but really, how hard is it to implement this?
Why is there talk about all this budget and cost and cost
effectiveness and all this? A human knows
how to blow a horn, why is there money behind it? Right? So just
educate them.
I've taken pics and videos of being blocked completely on both sides
and there is a housing development next door that is the Samsung
Lofts. And so if I'm blocked in as a business and they're blocked
in at their homes if anything were to happen, I know
there's a chemical company that works next door. If that something were to happen,
catch on fire, we have no place to go.
And listening to the Fire in Chief expresses the concerns of
being alert of train blockage made me realize this Uber
technology has been around for twelve years now, and I work for
a logistics company who has adopted this technology back in 2015
to monitor the driving routes of their trash trucks.
Why is it taking the Railroad Commission so long to implement
this technology? And you spoke about an app that
you have on your phone and you're going to pass that information to my friend
Tony Garcia. And why isn't the Royal Commission
adopting this technology? Alerting the Fire Chief
of train blockage. Thank you Mr. Segovia. And you have been joined
at the podium from Ms. Davis, from the city. Ms. Davis, if you'd like to
respond.
Okay, so as far as quiet zones go,
as the previous speaker mentioned,
priorities change and this is prior to me taking this role.
And so we have added more signature programs like the
Mayor Street Rehab Initiative to which we
aim to redo 2% of our roads every
year. We work very closely with the council members, the district council members on
that. So since coming into this role, we have been moving
some funding to the quiet zones. But there's a two part
effort. So there's the part on the city where we have
the five that we have right now that are pending, where we're doing our portion
of that, whether it's upgrading the
pavement markings or the channelization for
the cars. So that is something that we do on our side.
But it is an effort when we do the quiet zones, because there
are times when there are things that need to happen on the rail side,
and we can't compel them to do it, but we do partner with
them on quiet zones. And so that's just generally what can take so long.
And so I do have a staff person. Part of their role is quiet
zones and part is school zones, but we are
moving forward with the ones that are pending.
Thank you for that discussion and explanation. We appreciate that.
And without any comments or
council members in the queue, we want to thank you for being here today.
I didn't see that. Council Member Gallegos. Go ahead. Thank you,
Chair. Thank you for being here today. I know you were asking about quiet
zones there around Samson and York.
Again, that's where we've submitted to Congresswoman
Garcia and Congresswoman Sheila Jackson Lee for
community project funding for that area
right in there for a quiet zone.
And it's estimated that it will cost about $3.6 million
to convert those crossings right in there into a quiet
zone. So I can only ask that you and your neighbors and
businesses in the area please contact Congresswoman Sylvia Garcia,
congresswoman Sheila Jackson Lee, and let them know that the
city of Houston has asked for them to secure
some funding from community project funding, these $3.6 million
so we can address that. Great. Thank you. Yeah. And then I will add that's
the one of ours that's a priority for grade separation. And so we have
that. We're at about 30% design. And so those are ones that
when the notice of funding becomes available, again, depending on the criteria,
that is one at the top of our list to submit to get the funding
so that we can close the gap. And the Chair will note
also that with our partnering with our federal friends,
the aforementioned Congress folks, Sheila Jackson Lee and
Sylvia Garcia, with the new return of potential earmarks
and funding, some things have
changed with the IIja, and we will continue to pursue every opportunity
to work with those available funds. So thank you again,
both, and Council member for your response. We're going
to turn to our final signed up speaker, Mr. Juan Paras.
Did I hear from here he is. Mr. Paras, thank you for
being here. Coming to
the podium, if you identify yourself for the record.
Yes, sir. Thank you. My name is Juan Paras,
and I live in the East End.
Pardon me. Go ahead. Okay. And I live
almost at the corner of Lockwood and Harrisburg and
Rusk runs parallel to the Harrisburg rail line.
And I've heard a lot of good issues raised,
but nobody's raised the issue of why
don't the railway arts just expand their railway yards facility
so the trains can have a place to park?
Because they're so often blocking our communities that
I consider that their parking lot, their unofficial parking
lot. And if they have to pay
for parking there, I think we would generate a lot of money for the city.
So that's just another idea. But needless
to say, this is also an environmental justice issue.
The East End is inundated with environmental justice
issues, train traffic, 18 wheelers running on
our streets, and numerous issues
that impact our communities and standard of living.
So I would propose that one of the ideas is to
expand the rail yards or to penalize or
give fines. Like when you're parking at a meter and it
expires, you get a penalty, right? You pay a fine.
If we had something like that, it may encourage the railroad
industry to expand their rail yards
and accommodate the traffic that's coming into Houston.
Thank you, Mr. Paris. Thank you. Sounds so sensible and
easy. I don't know if our chair of the regulatory affairs, who handles all
parking issues in the ordinance, if you want to think about a levy for
the train companies. Do we have any interest in responding from
BNSF or up? Ms.
Davis or please come forward,
sir. Thank you for your question. Again,
for the record, if you could identify yourselves.
Thank you, Mr. Chairman. This is Tessa Minor from BNSF. I just wanted
to respond to I'm sorry, I missed his name.
Just wanted to respond, Mr. Paris, mr. Paras,
I appreciate that. Unfortunately, the railroads were built hundreds of
years ago, and Houston is built at city around the railroads.
And so that limits our capacity to expand our yards.
Okay, there's one answer. How about you, Mr. ZenTek? So,
I would say the capacity projects that I was talking about going on at
Inglewood, we are looking at what
improvements can be made, some of which we had talked about earlier, between the signal
upgrades as well as within the yard itself. So there are those projects that
we're looking at continuing to make a number of various
investments within the state of Texas related to our siding projects to be
able to accommodate the growth.
For the record, are you two and your companies both officially
against a parking fee?
I believe the fifth no. Yes,
I'm against it. Jokes aside, appreciate creative solutions,
and we are looking for ways in which to address these concerns.
So thank you all again for being here. Thank you, Mr. Chairman. Thank you.
Yes, we're now at the end of our list.
We have now a point where we'd like to make a last
call for those speakers who have not.
Hello? Can you hear me? We are calling for one last round.
Yes, who's on the line, please? Hi, this is Melissa
Bealer from Air Alliance, Houston. Say your name,
please, one more time. Melissa Bealer.
Melissa Bealer. Very good. Go ahead with your comment or
your question. Thank you. Good afternoon,
council members. Again, my name is Melissa and I'm with the
transportation justice coordinator for air Alliance Houston,
who envisions healthy communities with clean air
every day for everyone. I don't want to take up too much time.
I just want to say that we are in support of our neighbors and our
community partners in requesting improved conditions
to rail operations in Houston. We understand
and also express the same frustrations that the
community does in terms of the fact that while we are looking at
solutions today with railroad companies, it's been a long
time coming. And communities, these are
the communities that often get the harms as opposed
to the benefits of our transportation system. And there's
definitely some cumulative impact issues compounding
with pollution from the port and the highways.
Communities are concerned about train pollution while
idling as well. So that might be something that industry
could speak to a bit in terms of whether
or not the best available technology to reduce or eliminate emissions
while Idling and while we deal with these train blockages are
in fact happening for Houston. I also wanted to mention my
own experiences with train blockages,
having visited Magnolia Park when I was working with
community members to learn more about the improvements that they'd like to see for
the braze bayou trail. We tried to go visit
a trailhead, the best trailhead that they can visit at
capitol street, right behind
the multi service center there. And a train
was blocking the trailhead, so we had to go walk to wayside
where it has very narrow sidewalk. It's honestly
gravel in some places and not a sidewalk. And we're facing three
lanes of oncoming car traffic. Thank you. Trying to go
in like a single mile line. Thank you, Ms. Bealer, for your comments today
and for joining us online. Thank you very much. I think
Ms. Ruby Thomas may be online. We're looking again for Ms.
Thomas. Ruby, are you there?
If so, speak up or hit star six.
I think we're having challenges with getting you online. We're going to call
one last time for Ms. Virginia Ivanyez.
Understanding you may have joined us back online.
Understand, Ms. Thomas, you may be trying
to unmute hit star six on your phone.
Speak up. We'd love to hear from you. And if we can't hear
from you, you can always submit your question to any of the
chairs who are co sponsoring this meeting. That's council Member Sally
Alcorn, council Member Robert Gallegos or myself, council Member David
Robinson. So with that,
I'm going to call for any final speakers.
Last time for any speakers to hit SAR
six or speak up. I think
we have come to the end of our time. Council members, I'd like to thank
you for being here, your staff and all members of the public, both online virtually
as well as in the chamber. For final comments,
let me call first on council member Robert Gallegos.
Thank you, chair. I was in the queue. I just wanted to thank
Mr. Padas for your years of advocacy in
our community addressing environmental issues. So thank you
for everything that you do in the community. Let me
again thank all the public speakers who testified today and shared
the very serious issues they're seeing and filling
in our community due to poor rail operations.
As I told up back in January, and I say to be an SF
today, it is of utmost importance that the
railroads work collaboratively with cities and communities
to identify and implement mutual
beneficial solutions. We can no longer
accept prolonged blockages lasting four
and 8 hours and even 14 hours.
As it was learned today, blocking major
thoroughfares and neighborhood streets leaves residents
stranded, frustrated, and first responders
must scramble to find alternate, longer routes.
And as we all know, every second counts in emergency
responses. Prolonged blockages
are unacceptable and must be corrected. I ask
the railroads to please work with us, to remain engaged
and operate more responsibly.
Finally, let me thank Director Jesse Bounds,
jack Hanigriff, and all the partners
recognized earlier for all they've done to get us to this
point and for working with my office to bring this pilot
to fruition. I really do appreciate their work
and dedication. The findings they previewed with us
today support citizen observations and
complaints about blocked city streets and critical
crossings. And as we noted, the data gathered
through this pilot will be utilized to better understand,
manage and control the impacts of block crossings
and to inform and encourage data driven collaboration
between communities, federal regulators, and the railroad
companies. Again, thank you all and let's
all continue to work together. Thank you. Thank you.
Council Member. Council Member alcorn. Thank you, Chair. And thank you,
Council Member Gallegos. I certainly can improve on that. What I do want
to say, what I heard from residents today was about a comprehensive
plan, some kind of knowledge of when
your grade crossing or your quiet zone might be
in the queue. So I want to talk more with public Works
about a comprehensive plan to address these, especially with all these infrastructure
dollars available. Thank you to the railroads for coming. We need you.
Our city economy, state and national economy need the trains.
We all just have to figure out how we can better get along and be
better neighbors. Thank you. Thank you, council member. And again,
thank you to all of our participants today, those who've presented staff
and council for their support and attendance today, I want
to remind the public and urge the community to continue reporting
instances of blocked crossings to www dot FRA
dot gov blockedcrossings,
and to call Union Pacific at 188-87-7267.
Want to thank again council members Robert Gallegos and Council Member Sally
Alcorn and their teams for participating with us.
All of these presentations will be compiled and
placed online for the public to see in future reference.
And with that, I want to thank everyone again and. We are
adjourned.